this is the Dave Ramsey show you can
follow me on Twitter if you'd like at
Dave Ramsey Haley says how can an
enlisted person that is going to make
the military a career retire a
millionaire well Haley if you're going
to make the military a career even in
the military you will get promotions as
you go along if you do your job and you
know do do the things you're supposed to
do and so you're not going to be locked
in at just your entry-level pay and I
mean if you if you enter as a private
and forty years later you leave as a
private in any industry we would call
that a loser okay not because you served
in the military but because you had
absolutely no ability to get any kind of
a promotion in 40 years that would just
be horrendous that's just so far below
average that it's unbelievable so but
even at that if you were to save from a
in the in the TSP that the military has
available Thrift Savings Plan you put it
all in the see plan the see plan the
average on the see plan has been ten
point oh nine percent as of today that's
the average it's been over the last many
many many years okay and like 20 25 30
years so if you save money in the see
plan and it made 10 percent which is its
track record and you did that from age
25 to age 65 if you put in a hundred and
sixty dollars a month into that you
would have put you would have a million
dollars and that would make you a
millionaire now one hundred sixty
dollars a month it is only two thousand
dollars a year okay uh nineteen hundred
and twenty dollars to be exact a year
and we tell you to save fifteen percent
of your income and that would mean
you're only making thirteen thousand
dollars a year and I don't think the
military pays that low so if you stay
out of debt have your emergency fund in
place and you say fifteen percent of
your income if you're making like
twenty-six
in ours a year you're going to do that
twice as fast in Lourdes you're going to
have if you did you you know you'd have
be putting in not 160 but you'll be
putting in 320 and you get to
millionaire status a lot faster so
that's that's not much money you're
making $26,000 a year at that point your
whole life and honestly if you make if
you enter anything making $26,000 a year
that's fine I've made less than that but
if you exit 40 years later still making
only $26,000 you want your whole life
and never got a raise I think we can all
agree that's a loser all right so that's
how you would do it if you just took
that exact snapshot and extrapolated it
through your whole life this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income